jenz speaks out on the simple act that
brings them to tears with phones being
so easily accessible and attached to
almost every Young Person's hand you
might expect genen Z to be able to
perform one of the most mundane tasks
picking up the phone and dialing
unfortunately the reality is the very
thought of making a call is often
accompanied by a sense of dread and
impending failure ow ow you're hurting
me they are the first generation of
humans in world history to be raised in
an environment where a majority of their
communication is not done through spoken
language they've been conditioned to
communicate through memes and gifts and
emojis and choppy internet slang and and
and run-on sentences if you miss them
why don't you call them it's like
expecting a child raised by wolves in
the forest to come back to civilization
and hold a coherent conversation with
you it's just not going to happen now
with all that said they are not wrong
about phone calls though it is true that
this is there is very rarely a good
reason for a phone call to be made if
you're going to communicate with someone
in a nonface to-face format it can
almost always be handled quicker and
more efficiently with a text or email